also da wurde ja heute in den
vergangenen Tagen bereits in der Bundes
von der Bundesregierung die Passage
rausgenommen vom von der Homepage und
Gesundheitsministerium wo es geheißen
hat sind gemäß das sei alles Fake News
wenn Leute darüber sprechen würden das
eine allgemeine Impfpflicht kommen
könnte ist das schon Zeichen dafür ich
spreche hier definitiv nicht also im
Namen also der sage mal das noch
amtierenden Gesundheitsministers oder
ist Robert-Koch-Instituts aber ich bin
sage mal mit allen also im engen Kontakt
und also die Zahl derer die eine
Impfpflicht für notwendig hält wächst
mal bei einem respekt das ist doch das
ist doch wieder das nächste versprechen
dass sie dann brechen würden da sitzt
der das ehemalige oder der dann
ehemalige Gesundheitsminister hat
monatelang gesagt eine Impfpflicht wird
es nicht geben Angela Merkel hat gesagt
es wird nicht dem Olaf Scholz dass wir
Nebenfluss sie können doch dann damit
untergraben sie doch das Vertrauen
völlig natürlich das ist richtig also
das
untergräbt Vertrauen ohne wenn aber wir
müssen anfangen darüber nachzudenken
wenn die also Epidemiologie es notwendig
macht dann kann ich nicht sagen es ist
zwar jetzt unbedingt notwendig aber weil
ich damals anders gesprochen habe mache
ich völlig egal was man früher gesagt
hat alles kriegt könnte den Menschen das
Blau vom Himmel versprechen und dann
nehmen Sie alles wieder zurück nein nein
egal ist was anderes also ich muss dann
begründen damals haben wir noch geglaubt
das geht ohne jetzt sehen wir dass also
in der Kombination jeder soll ihn denn
noch irgendwas Glauben Herr Lauterbach
auf jeden Fall nur die Leute die mir
zuhören wenn sie mich aussprechen lassen
sonst wäre es nicht funktionieren also
ich wäre ich versuche ja gerade zu
erklären was ich geändert hat und dann
also das ist ja schon mal die
Voraussetzung dass man jetzt mal
erklären kann was neu ist neu ist wir
erreichen ohne Impfpflicht erreichen wir
offensichtlich die also Impfquote nicht
die wir benötigen um bei der Stärke der
Impfstoffe die wir haben und dem also
R-Wert des der Variante über die Runden
zu kommen also das sind ja immer drei
Parameter also sozusagen wie stark sind
unsere Impfstoffe wie lange wirken die
wie stark wie schnell wie stark
ansteckend ist das Virus und wie hoch
ist die Impfquote und wir haben jetzt
das folgende Problem die Impfstoffe
werden etwas schneller unwirksam die
Zahl der die sich nicht impfen lassen
will ist größer und daher also müssen
wir an dem Rad drehen also wie kriegen
wir mehr zur Impfungen da kann eine
Impfpflicht aus meiner Sicht richtig
sein ich würde das auf keinen Fall mehr
ausschließen und tendiere dazu zu sagen
das hilft uns jetzt nicht akut aber wir
müssen uns eine Impfpflicht nähern das
ist so Außenminister maas hat hier am
Freitag gesagt dass es alleine rechtlich
schwer möglich ich möchte einmal die
Frage weitergeben an Michael teurer
fDP-Fraktionsvize der gehandelt wird
auch für Ministerposten im neuen
Kabinett der teurer wenn Sie das Hören
also jetzt ruckelt auch das Versprechen
dass eine Impfpflicht kommen nicht
kommen soll wie gehen Sie damit um
also zunächst mal ist die Aufgabe vor
der wir alle stehen immens die
Geschäftsführer der Bundesregierung muss
die Zeit nutzen die Sie derzeit hat die
Menschen erwarten das eben auch vom
geschäftsführenden
Bundesgesundheitsminister das was sie
nutzt denn
Intensivstationen und darauf hat
Lauterbach hingewiesen die sind sehr
sehr voll ich habe mich an Unikliniken
gerade jetzt das wissen wir teurer meine
Frage war was ist mit der Impfpflicht ja
ja aber das was wir jetzt sehen sind die
Versäumnisse der vergangenen Wochen da
liegen also jetzt die Patienten die sich
vor einigen Wochen angesteckt haben und
deshalb ist es so wir brauchen eine
höhere Impfquote impfen und testen sind
die zwei Seiten einer Medaille wir sind
deshalb auch gerade intensiv dran zu
prüfen ob wir eine
impfnachweispflicht für bestimmte
Berufsgruppen einführen gegenüber einer
allgemeinen Impfpflicht haben wir
massive
Verfassungsbeschwerden da gibt es auch
Gutachten dass die nicht so einfach
führen ist deshalb lohnt auch noch mal
einen Blick nach Israel die haben es ja
geschafft die Inzidenz auf 33 zu drücken
ohne Impfpflicht ich versprechen
sich hier dass es mit der FDP keine
allgemeine Impfpflicht geben wird wir
halten die für verfassungswid
versprechen sie das ich wir sind nicht
dafür und wir halten sie für
verfassungswidrig und ich bin der
Meinung dass das Grundgesetz eine gute
Verfassung ist versprechen
sie das auch ihren Wählerinnen und
Wählern dass es eine Impfpflicht eine
allgemeine Impfpflicht mit der FDP nicht
geben wird ich habe gerade auf verwiesen
dass wir sie für verfassungswidrig
halten und deshalb ist sie in
Deutschland so nicht einführbar und ich
verweise auf Israel dies ohne
impfpflichtschacht durch Testen und den
schutzwunder haben Gruppen und durch
impfen die Inzidenz auf 33 zu drücken
und darauf sollten wir uns konzentrieren
aber das bedeutet ja ein teurer sie
lassen sich jetzt eine Hintertür offen
sie sagen ist verfassungswidrig
möglicherweise was ist wenn es nicht
verfassungswidrig ist kann macht die FDP
dann damit
also wir wollen das nicht und wir halten
es mit unserem Grundgesetz nicht für
vereinbar und wir setzen auf die
Überzeugung aber damit keine
Missverständnisse aufkommen wir sind
dafür dass sich jeder der das
medizinisch tun kann also der gesund ist
impfen lässt ich werbe also hier an der
Stelle noch mal ganz klar fürs impfen
und ich bin auch der Meinung dass der
moderner Impfstoff genommen werden kann
aber ich kritisiere das jetzt eben nicht
der in Deutschland sehr beliebte
Impfstoff biontech in ausreichender
Menge offensichtlich zur Verfügung steht
ich möchte noch kurz bei der Impfpflicht
bleiben Herr teurer Herr Palma wie sehen
Sie die Debatte um die allgemeine
Impfpflicht wenn wir jetzt hören der
Lauterbach ist dafür Herr teurer sagt
dies verfassungsrütig gehen Sie davon
aus dass am Ende eine ampelregierung
diese mit beschließen wird
weiß ich nicht aber ich kann Satz dazu
sagen was ich für nötig halte
wo anderthalb Jahren hielt ich es für
nötig dass wir eine kontaktverfolgung
bekommen und uns über
Datenschutzbedenken hinwegsetzen hatten
wir bis heute nur Ärger eingebracht wir
haben keine funktionierende
kontaktverfolgung jetzt haben wir einen
Impfstoff der könnte die Probleme lösen
wenn ihr nur genügend benutzen würden
ich habe festgestellt die erste Phase
der Argumente die ist vorbei mit
Argumenten scheint man niemand mehr zu
überzeugen dann wurde mit Druck
gearbeitet dann ist die Zahl der
erstimpfungen aber gar nicht angestiegen
im September und Oktober sind die erste
Impfungen auf extrem niedrigen Niveau
geblieben und jetzt stellt sich ja schon
die Frage wenn wir ohne Impfungen kaum
eine Chance haben diese in ewige Spirale
aus kontaktbeschränkungen und möglichen
Schulschließungen was da alles auf uns
zukommt zu durchbrechen was wollen wir
denn dann tun mit Argumenten klappt es
nicht mit Druck und Kosten und 2G hat es
nicht geklappt
und dann scheint mir irgendwie ziemlich
logisch zu sein zu sagen okay diese
Gesellschaft die braucht jetzt eine Form
des Zusammenhalts Pflicht ist ja auch
nichts Böses sondern Pflicht spürt man
erstmal selber und die gießen wir in
Form eines Gesetzes ich finde es
schlüssig weil wir anders nicht
vorangekommen sind leider muss man
manchmal zu solchen Konsequenzen greifen
und ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen
dass es verfassungswidrig ist denn es
gibt ja immerhin eine Masern Impfpflicht
und ich kann jetzt nicht erkennen dass
Masern unsere Gesellschaft in so
gravierender Weise bedroht wie es
derzeit die corona-pandemie tut aber
wegen wegen Masern eigentlich doch keine
Kontakte Beschränkungen oder
schwerwiegenden gesellschaftlichen
Eingriffe in Grundrechte und Freiheiten
vorgenommen deswegen meine ich das ist
zulässig ist und das ist allmählich Zeit
wird zu diesem Instrument zu kommen